Bonjour!
Nouvelle rentrée, nouveau thème et nouveau
lieu de tournage pour cet épisode! Tout
le monde est bien installé?
-Que veux-tu que je dise, je ne suis même
pas descendue de mon canapé pendant le déménagement!
-Ouais, on s'en souvient! Et Aliénor, ça
va?
-J'préférais la cheminée.
-Bon, on peut commencer!
Pour cet épisode j'ai décidé de m'intéresser
au druidisme, car comme beaucoup de peuples,
de groupe ou de croyances de l'Antiquité,
on en a une vision largement faussée par
les diverses interprétations et réécritures
qu'ils ont subi.
Genre Panoramix, mais pas que.
On va donc faire le bilan de toutes les croyances
qui se sont succédé sur les druides avant
de présenter ce qu'on sait réellement sur
eux.
Générique.
La première chose à se demander, c'est qui
a écrit sur les druides? Est-ce qu'il y
a des observateurs contemporains des druides
qui ont pris leur jolie plume pour décrire
leur rôle?
-Non, pas toi, t'es une fausse contemporaine.
La première mention écrite des druides date
de la fin du IIIe siècle avant J.C., dans
le traité grec La Magie.
Bien avant la conquête romaine, donc.
On les retrouve dans d'autres ouvrages grecs
du IIe siècle avant J.C.
comme le Stromateis, l'Histoire de la philosophie
de Sotion d'Alexandrie ou l'Histoire de la
philosophie de Diogène Laërce.
-De la philosophie? Qu'est-ce que des barbares
auraient à voir avec la philosophie?
-Pour les grecs, «barbare» voulait dire
étranger qui ne partage pas la culture grecque.
C'était plutôt neutre, comme terme, alors
pourquoi pas.
-Mais, comment elle sait ça, elle?
-J'ai lu le début du script.
-Effectivement, les grecs étaient en contact
avec les peuples celtes au moins depuis Hérodote,
qui les décrit au Ve siècle avant J.C.,
et nous livre donc quelques descriptions des
celtes et des gaulois, de leurs mœurs et
de leur religion.
D'ailleurs, pour faire simple et même si
c'est une généralisation puisqu'ils étaient
constitués d'un grand nombre de peuples,
on va dire que les gaulois sont des celtes
vivant au second âge de fer, entre -500 et
le début de notre ère, en France, Belgique,
Allemagne cisrhénane, Suisse et Italie cisalpine.
Les grecs présentent donc les druides comme
des philosophes.
On reviendra sur leur rôle précis dans la
société gauloise plus tard, mais ils sont
comparés à d'autres sages orientaux ou grecs,
comme Pythagore, et parfois présentés comme
les «pères de la philosophie», rien
que ça.
Et en les présentant ainsi, les grecs semblent
être plus proches de la vérité que tous
les auteurs qui leur ont succédé.
Dans son Histoire de la philosophie, Diogène
Laërce résume plusieurs aspects de la sagesse
druidique:
-Ils forment un ensemble et ont une place
à part dans la société, qui les positionne
au dessus des autres.
-Ils parlent aux hommes par maximes et propos
énigmatiques.
-Parce que c'est vachement mystérieux.
-Et ils ont des principes simples: honorer
les dieux, ne pas faire le mal, être brave.
Et ça paraît assez évident, comme principes
à suivre de nos jours, mais à l'époque
c'était déjà une sacré réflexion sur
la vie.
«ne pas faire le mal», ça s'est plutôt
répandu chez nous grâce à notre société
judéo-chrétienne.
-Tu ne tueras point.
-Donc à l'époque il fallait bien être philosophe
pour penser à ça.
C'est à partir des descriptions des druides
par les romains que les choses se gâtent:
on ne sait pas si les grecs avaient un but
derrière la description des druides, mais
pour les romains c'est clairement le cas!
Par exemple César, lors de la guerre des
Gaules, en fait une description très positive
parce qu'il cherche à faire passer les gaulois
pour des gens un peu civilisés.
Il décrit donc les druides comme des sages,
des éducateurs, des prêtres...
Des gens bien, quoi.
C'est d'ailleurs à partir de César et de
Cicéron qu'on commence à décrire les druides,
parce que durant les siècle précédents.
Pff, aucun intérêt.
-Et alors? On avait des rapports diplomatiques
et commerciaux avec les gaulois, quel intérêt
de savoir qu'ils vénéraient le dieu machin
ou le temple chose...
-Et voilà, les gens sont pas intéressants
tant qu'on peut pas en tirer profit! Belle
mentalité les romains!
-Oui, mais...
On s'y est intéressés ensuite! On a même
un druide, Diviciac, qui est venu à Rome,
et qui nous a appris des tas de choses sur
son art...
Science...
Chose.
-Les descriptions des romains restent vagues,
parfois inspirées des écrits grecs, mais
pleines d'approximation.
Par exemple c'est là qu'apparaît le mythe
du sacrifice humain pratiqué par les druides,
les réduisant à un rôle de grand-prêtre.
Et pourquoi les descriptions des romains du
Ier siècle avant J.C.
Sont-elles si vagues, me direz-vous? Ben
c'est qu'il y avait déjà plus trop de druides
en circulation à cette époque, en fait.
Fini l'âge d'or du druidisme, tout ça.
Mais on reviendra dessus ensuite.
-Pourtant Pline l'Ancien, Lucain, Tacite ont
écrit de si beaux textes sur les druides.
Tellement poétiques...
-Poétiques, c'est le mot, mais en rien fidèles
à la réalité.
A partir du Ier siècle après J.C., les druides
sont soit présentés comme de vieux sages
habillés en blanc, soit comme des barbares
qui pratiquent le sacrifice humain.
-Merlin J'ai tout entendu et c'est honteux!!
Par exemple, l'un des rares témoignages sur
des druides en Bretagne nous vient de Tacite,
vers 140 après J.C., et raconte la prise
de l'île de Mona par les troupes romaines:
«Sur le rivage l'armée ennemie faisait
face, dense en armes et en hommes; parmi
elles couraient des femmes semblables à des
furies, les cheveux dénoués et portant des
torches.
Autour d'elles des druides, les mains tournées
vers le ciel, répandaient d'affreuses imprécations;
l'étrangeté de ce spectacle ébranla les
soldats qui comme si leurs membres étaient
paralysés, s'offraient aux coups sans bouger.»
«Dès lors une garnison fut installée
chez les ennemis et leurs bois sacrés voués
à de sauvages superstitions furent rasés:
car ils croyaient pieux d'honorer leurs autels
du sang des prisonniers et de consulter les
dieux dans leurs entrailles.»
Alors Tacite était pas là, il raconte les
événements 50 ans après, et rien que le
fait que les druides étaient exemptés de
service militaire nous fait dire: quel est
le fuck? On ne sait même pas s'il y avait
des druides sur cette île, alors ils étaient
encore moins au milieu des combats.
-Dis nous des choses que tu sais, alors, pas
du rien.
-Je déconstruis un mythe.
C'est pas de ma faute si à ton époque personne
ne s'intéressait aux gaulois.
La culture antique, ça vous passait bien
au dessus.
-Pardon? Et qu'est-ce que tu fais de Geoffroi
de Monmouth? Dans son Histoire de la Bretagne,
il parle des celtes et des druides.
Il explique que l'ancêtre des Bretons descend
d'Enée en personne.
Et il présente le roi Arthur, aussi, et Myyrdhinn,
l'espèce de prêtre-guerrier qui l'accompagne.
Et qui a inspiré le personnage de Merlin,
qui est un mythe.
Ouais.
-C'est bon, je peux continuer? Les textes
antiques traitant des gaulois sont surtout
redécouverts durant la Renaissance.
On s'intéresse aussi aux ruines héritées
de l'Antiquité, mais c'est à cette époque
qu'apparaît le léger anachronisme qui veut
que les dolmens et les menhirs aient été
construits par les gaulois.
Y'a juste au moins 3000 ans d'écart entre
les dolmens et les premiers gaulois, c'est
pas grand chose après tout.
Cependant le courant humaniste du XVIe siècle
s'intéresse davantage aux grecs et aux latins
qu'aux celtes, parce qu'ils montrent un modèle
plus intéressant d'après eux.
Du coup, pendant une longue période, les
gaulois et les druides sont encore mis de
côté.
A cette époque et jusqu'au XIXe on ne parle
d'ailleurs pas de nos ancêtres les gaulois,
on préfère dire que les français descendent
des francs.
-C'est quand même un petit peu plus classe
que descendre de barbares moustachus.
-Ça tombe bien! Cette image là apparaît
au XIXe siècle, en plein Roman National où
on essaie de trouver des ancêtres combatifs
aux français pour se mettre bien face aux
autres peuples.
J'en ai déjà un peu parlé dans ma petite
vidéo sur le Roman National, alors je vais
pas m'attarder sur la vision des gaulois au
XIXe siècle mais pour ce qui est des druides,
leur importance est grandement minimisée
à cette époque par les «historiens»
du Roman National.
Vu l'importance des druides dans la société
gauloise, ça collait pas vraiment avec l'image
de guerriers pas très instruits que voulaient
créer Michelet et compagnie.
Alors on réduit les druides à des vieux
barbus habillés en blancs, qui vivent dans
la forêt et cueillent le gui avec une serpe.
C'est dommage, parce qu'en 1828 l'historien
Amédée Thierry avait écrit L'Histoire des
Gaulois, que je n'ai pas lue mais qui apparemment
dressait un portrait des druides beaucoup
plus proche de la réalité.
Enfin, toujours est-il que l'image des druides
continue d'inspirer de nombreuses personnes,
auteurs...
Jusqu'à des groupes se revendiquant du néo-druidisme,
comme le Druid Order qui existe depuis 1716
et vise à restaurer la tradition druidique.
-Et en parlant de tradition, je pense qu'il
serait temps de présenter qui étaient vraiment
les druides.
-Ouais, ça va bien 5mn ton historiographie.
On veut des faits, nous!
-Dans ce cas on va commencer notre présentation
des druides par un point étymologie!
-Ooooh...
Les druides se font eux-même appeler druides.
C'est un mot gaulois, mais dont les racines
sont probablement grecques.
Il peut venir du mot «drus», qui signifie
chêne, rapport à la forêt que les druides
aiment tant, et de «weid» qui signifie
«voir et «savoir». Ça donnerait
donc «le savant par le chêne», c'est
joli, mais ça veut pas dire grand chose.
Ça, c'est l'interprétation antique.
Au XIXe le linguiste Rudolf Thurneysen suggère
que «dru» est une particule qui renforce
le mot, ça donnerait donc «le très savant».
Ça a davantage de sens, mais ça reste une
théorie.
Les druides étaient sûrement les héritiers
d'autres personnalités importantes durant
l'âge de bronze, parce qu'un groupe d'une
telle importance n'a pas pu apparaître d'un
claquement de doigts.
Ils étaient très probablement inspirés
dans leurs idées et leur mode de vie par
le philosophe Pythagore, dont ils connaissaient
l'existence.
Il est possible que des druides aient rencontré
des élèves de Pythagore, et on trouve de
nombreux points communs entre les deux groupes:
Déjà, la croyance en la réincarnation et
l'immortalité de l'âme.
Qui dit réincarnation dit recherche du bien
pour sortir du cycle de réincarnation et
atteindre une sorte de Paradis, encore une
idée nouvelle: ces théories étaient développées
par Pythagore et par les druides, qui pensaient
que la fin du monde amènerait la destruction
des âmes immortelles.
Comme les pythagoriciens, les druides s'interrogeaient
sur la nature de l'univers, s'habillaient
en blanc pour montrer leur pureté, et divulguaient
leur enseignement en secret, dans des endroits
reculés et à l'oral uniquement.
Par contre les pythagoriciens et les druides
n'occupaient pas la même place dans la société.
Et l'autre différence entre les deux tient
à leur alimentation et leur rapport au sacrifice:
JE SUIS VEGAN !
Pythagore encourageait le végétarisme et
était contre les sacrifices d'animaux, parce
que l'âme de ces animaux avait peut-être
appartenu à un humain avant, alors ça se
fait pas.
-Philippe, c'est toi?
-Les druides n'étaient pas d'accord avec
ça, et pensaient qu'un homme se réincarnait
forcément en homme, donc le reste, on pouvait
le manger.
Les druides avaient donc plusieurs utilités
dans la société gauloise.
Ils étaient impliqués dans le domaine de
la religion, puisque la présence d'un druide
était nécessaire aux sacrifices, aux cérémonies
religieuses, et c'est aussi eux qui décidaient
où installer un sanctuaire gaulois.
-Au hasard, dans la forêt?
-Oui, mais le lieu exact dépendait de questions
astronomiques, de calculs...
Bref, il n'y avait donc pas de religion druidique,
n'en déplaise aux romains, mais une religion
gauloise dans laquelle les druides avaient
leur importance.
-Je trouve que mon peuple est un peu trop
déconsidéré dans cette vidéo.
-Puisque les druides sont calés en astronomie,
ils mettent aussi leurs connaissances en application
pour réaliser des calendriers perpétuels,
comme le calendrier de Coligny, dans lequel
un siècle dure 30 ans.
Il prend en compte les cycles solaires et
lunaires.
-C'est formidable, comme ça les gueux du
Moyen-Âge pourront se vanter de vivre un
siècle!
-Ils pratiquaient aussi la physiologie, qui
est un mélange de physique, de chimie, géologie,
botanique, zoologie...
Bref, ils étaient calés, et pour en arriver
à un tel niveau de connaissance il fallait
bien qu'ils aient reçu un enseignement solide.
L'initiation des druides était longue et
confidentielle.
-Titre.
-La formation durait 20 ans, et était réservée
à l'élite gauloise.
On ne sait rien sur les conditions matérielles
de cette formation, si les élèves vivaient
chez leur maître pendant ce temps, ou s'ils
avaient plusieurs maîtres selon les spécialités...
Comme il n'y avait pas de vie communautaire
chez les druides, ils pouvaient fonder une
famille, avoir une maison...
il n'y avait pas une école druidique.
Et la formation se faisait à l'oral, pour
rester confidentielle.
Les druides tenaient tellement au secret qu'ils
interdisaient tout simplement l'écriture
à la population gauloise, comme ça on prend
pas de risque.
-Mais s'ils devaient communiquer avec d'autres
peuples?
-Oui, là y'avait exception.
-Pour le commerce, aussi, il faut bien passer
par l'écrit.
-Dans ce cadre là, c'était toléré.
-Et tu as parlé de calendriers rédigés
par les druides, tout à l'heure?
-Là aussi, les druides privaient les autres
d'écriture mais pour eux, pas de problème.
On suppose qu'il y avait différentes communautés
de druides, dirigées par un maître, avec
peut-être parfois des divergences dans les
idées des différentes communautés, et ces
groupes se réunissaient de temps en temps.
-Ah, oui, attendez! C'est un Eduen qui entre
dans un bar...
-Tu fais quoi là?
-Je me prépare pour un rassemblement druidique.
-Laisse tomber, c'est sans alcool.
-Durant ces rassemblement, ils rendent la
justice.
C'est pas tellement la grosse ambiance.
Il existe aussi des assises annuelles en pays
Carnute, habilement nommées les assises des
Carnutes.
-Tant qu'on doit pas rester debout...
-Les gaulois étaient divisés en plein de
peuples, mais avaient en commun une religion
et des druides, qu'on retrouvait dans les
différents peuples et qui assuraient donc
l'unité spirituelle des gaulois.
Pour un temps.
Tout ce que j'ai présenté jusqu'à maintenant
sur le rôle et le mode de vie des druides,
ça se passait avant la conquête romaine.
A partir du IIe siècle avant J.C., l'importance
des druides commence à décliner.
Probablement parce que les druides prônaient
un mode de vie tourné vers la Gaule, pour
la Gaule,
-C'est la Gaule.
-Alors qu'à partir du IIe siècle av, les
peuples gaulois commencent à se tourner vers
la Méditerranée, ils créent des contacts
diplomatiques ou commerciaux.
Des divisions apparaissent, avec la création
d'une province romaine dans le Sud-Est, des
invasions par l'Est, des luttes internes...
Certains peuples gaulois reviennent à des
régimes politiques anciens, comme la royauté,
ou sont influencés par Rome et se rapprochent
de la démocratie pour changer.
Et les druides, dans tout ça, on n'en a plus
grand chose à faire.
- La boutique est fermée, adressez-vous à
la concurrence.
-Les grands rassemblements druidiques cessent,
et Diviciac, le seul druide dont on ait un
témoignage à travers Cicéron et qui vivait
au Ier siècle av, continue de se faire appeler
druide mais n'a gardé que deux aspects de
cette pratique: sa formation scientifique
et intellectuelle, et la divination.
Il n'a plus de rôle religieux, moralisateur,
et donc druide est surtout devenu un titre
honorifique à son époque.
-Pourtant Suétone et Tacite ont bien dit
que le druidisme avait continué clandestinement
sous l'Empire.
-Bah c'est faux, hein.
Mais ça fait toujours bien de raconter qu'on
a des ennemis clandestins à vaincre par ci-par
là.
Des personnes continuent de se faire appeler
druide bien après le Ier siècle, mais ils
font ça dans leur coin maintenant, des femmes
druidesses apparaissent aussi, mais leur savoir
s'est largement perdu.
Les druides de Gaule et de Bretagne, qui étaient
un peu moins développés que leurs confrères,
s'effacent définitivement au Ive siècle
et même le mot druide disparaît de la langue
galloise.
A partir du VIIIe siècle, les moines irlandais
décrivent des druides qui pratiquent la magie
avant d'être convertis au christianisme,
mais il s'agit d'une réutilisation tardive
d'un mot qui n'a plus aucun sens à cette
époque.
-Donc pour résumer, les druides historiques,
les vrais, étaient des philosophes scientifiques
religieux hommes politiques astrologues qui
ont surtout vécut entre le Ve et le IIe siècle
avant JC, et n'ont fait que décliner à partir
de là.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette émission...
-Oh, c'est moi, ça.
L'épisode du mois prochain portera sur un
sujet mystérieux, intriguant, et si vous
avez aimé cet épisode je peux vous conseiller
Jean-Louis Brunaux, un historien qui a travaillé
sur le sujet.
Et par un hasard complet, le numéro de septembre
de la revue Histoire porte aussi sur les gaulois
et les druides.
Rendez-vous le 1er novembre, donc, et en attendant
je vous laisse préparer vos meilleures blagues
pour le prochain rassemblement druidique!